hi this is mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video
we're going to talk about how to work
with inverse matrices using the TI 83 or
TI 84 so here we've got a system of
equations and what we're going to do is
we're going to write it as a matrix
equation so you can see what I've done
here I've just written the coefficients
the numbers in front of the X's and Y's
as a coefficient matrix I've got the
variable matrix X Y and have the
solution matrix- 35 so in order to get
the variable matrix by itself x and y we
have to take the inverse of the
coefficient matrix a if we multiply by
the coefficient matrix the inverse we
want to multiply that on the left side
of matrix a because and you multiply
with matrices it's not commutative so
you want to multiply by the inverse of a
okay on the left here and the inverse of
a here on the left of matrix B okay so
you want to do the same thing to both
sides of the equation to keep it
balanced when you multiply the matrix a
times its inverse you get the identity
matrix okay so identity matrix times any
other matrix it's just like multiplying
by the number one you just get the
matrix X by itself okay so x equals a
inverse B by multiplying the inverse of
the coefficient matrix times the
solution matrix you get the variable
matrix by itself so that's what we're
going to do but we're going to do it on
the calculator so let's go ahead and
turn on the calculator and what we're
going to do now is we're going to input
this matrix a so what you want to do is
you want to go over here to the second
key so second and then you see the
matrix key right here where it says X
minus 1 okay that's matrix we're going
to go over to edit enter and you can
enter the number of rows in the number
of columns in this case it's a two by
two two rows to columns and you can
arrow through okay and input all the
elements here now you can see I've
already done that one negative 2 3 1 but
then what you want to do and this is
where students forget this part you want
to go to 2nd quit so you want to go back
to the home screen you want to go then
go back into the matrix screen so 2nd
matrix okay and then you want to go down
to matrix B and you want to edit matrix
B ok enter so 2 x 12 rows one column and
you can see I've entered that
ready negative 35 okay but then what you
want to do is you want it once you enter
that you want to go to second quid back
to the home screen second Matrix okay
and you want to just select matrix a you
want to use the inverse key that's right
where the matrix key is okay so in verse
and then go back into the matrix menu
okay and select matrix B so you can see
we have a inverse B hit enter one more
time and you can see x equals 1 y equals
2 so X is the top value and why is the
bottom value there so I hope you found
this video helpful go ahead and
subscribe to the channel I've got more
videos on the ti-83 and TI 84 working
with those and i also have a lot of
number of math videos so go ahead and
check those out and i'll see you in the
next video talk to you soon